ross what's the scoop today well
everybody's talking i i don't know if
you've heard it but there is a song that
is taking over the world right now and
it's called
driver's license by have you heard it
by olivia rodrigo it's been out for less
than a week and variety says it's
already number one on spotify
apple music and amazon uh if
i actually was kind of out of the loop
on this i heard it yesterday for the
first time
okay why you got chills i'm obsessed
with it now it's been on repeat it's
about like that moment when you're 16
years old and you're
in love and then they're broken up with
i'm driving by your house you're
supposed to be in my car with me
i mean yes i understand honey listen to
me when you're 35 you'll remember this
guy's name i promise you
but it's so romantic do you remember
that feeling
uh kind of
um but i i listen i like being older
it's like i
i loved having all the experiences but i
love the calm i feel in my body now
and since i'm woken up and no longer
dead inside then you know this is a
perfect
pretty little middle as i like to call
it i know but listen i think i
i yearn for those days of romance though
because now i feel like if i wrote a
love song it'd be called like
you know what's your credit score which
is less romantic
right so i might probably back through
and i i mean literally this is like the
big news if you have kids or you want to
be in
on the know of what is really trending
in the world
this is the big story and i love
what you know several generations are
into like for me age is nothing but a
number
and uh it's an all-ages party and
everyone's invited but i really want to
get
our next guest's take on this song
we're so excited to have her here at the
news desk today she is a young
actress who plays missy cooper on the
smash hit
cbs comedy young sheldon take a look
missy what
help me with my clothes burn them and
get new ones
please it's freshman orientation i want
to make a good impression
fine which bowtie says mature enough to
be in college but whimsical enough to
discuss
which came first the higgs field or the
photon
they both say weird kid who eats alone
oh i'm such a fan please welcome reagan
reverend
hi so cute
so nice to meet you oh reagan
i am such a very nervous i'm a big fan
thank you no i know you're talking to
her i think she's speaking to both of
you
thank you reagan exactly we're fans of
yours great to meet you oh my gosh i'm
so excited
did you have you heard driver's license
and what do you think
i love it so much me and my family have
been listening to it constantly
and the guy who actually does my hair he
is a good friend of hers and we were
actually listening to it today
and i'm so excited to talk about it
because i love it so much
it's just so good it's very anthemic it
feels like that church feeling like it
hits that note and
we all want to feel that thing inside
that magnetic
pull to something bigger yeah
it's just such a sweet song and it i
feel like for a lot of people
people can relate to that and it's
really nice i think that's why people
are obsessed with the song people are
also obsessed with your show
young sheldon congratulations
and it's the prequel if you don't know
to the big bang theory it's set in the
80s um which was way before you were
born so
what were you most surprised about to
learn about the way we all had to live
back in the 80s
probably all the technology i was
confused by
the very concept of a wall phone
with the walkman let's just say that
scene took a while
yes and then i don't like the clothes
are really tight and itchy like you guys
grew up in the
you guys grew up in the 80s what did you
think of the clothes
i mean some of them i kind of liked i
mean the scrunchie i'm fine with stretch
pants i'd like some right now
um colorful a lot of flaps it was also
like
fishnet like gloves with bangles
and there was a lot of layers
yeah it gets very tight and because of
quarantine
i've been in like sweatpants and a
t-shirt
and so going back to work was even
harder because of all like the
overalls and jeans i hadn't worn those
in like eight months
yeah i i kick and scream trying to get
in some denim
um now you're in a hit comedy but i
heard you
want to do a horror movie is this true
yes i watched scream recently with a
friend
and i had to sleep with my parents for
probably three months because i was
traumatized
i am horrible at horror movies
absolutely horrible
i watched jaws when i was eight and i
would have a panic attack any time i had
to take a shower
i'm telling you i'm back at scary movies
you've got
and yet you want to be in one now if you
want to be in one you got to have a good
scream
and i've been practicing my screams my
whole life
in fact can i show you something sure
take a look
[Music]
i have seen that interview before and i
love it whenever you take out your
flipper and put it on the desk
have you ever had to wear a flipper uh
whenever we came back from quarantine to
the show
um i had lost my two front teeth
and since we were halfway through the
first slash last episode
um i had to wear flipper and
i i was only supposed to wear it for one
episode and then it turns out i had to
wear it for three episodes
yeah so well and to anyone who may not
know what a flipper is a flipper is
a retainer that has the missing
tooth on it um but reagan do you want to
practice
a horror movie scream together right now
sure
i bet you're so much better than it but
i mean but sure
all right i want to see this one two
three
yeah i'll accept that that was good
mine's really high pitched my mine went
too
i my my my vocal box went straight to
the magnet of yours and i went right in
your reign
um i um ross you have a story that i
think will speak to reagan well reagan i
thought
this is story i want to get your opinion
on it uh there's the advocate in back at
baton rouge they have a local elementary
school that just
started this new program where kids your
age who are in school
uh can go to a vending machine in in the
school
not for snacks but to get a book and it
doesn't take cash instead students earn
gold
tokens in the classroom and can cash
those tokens in
for the books and we know reagan that
just like drew you're a little bookworm
yep right you even have your own book
yeah too
yeah what do you think about this
vending machine look at you with all
those books
what do you think about a vending
machine like this
i want it so bad i love reading and it
would be my most
prized possession of all and
i would i would never let go of that
vending machine
like you said i love reading and that's
what actually
uh had me start my book club because
i all my friends were asking like what
was i reading
and i thought and i saw oprah had a book
club and reese witherspoon had a
book club but i saw that there were no
book clubs for like
teenagers and like kids
and i thought why not make my own and i
did and it's
and i kind of think of it as my
quarantine book club because it started
right whenever quarantine started well
reagan we have
um a correspondent on this show jonah
larson who reviews books and i've
always talked to him about doing a book
club he builds libraries
um back in his home in africa and we
just
i learned self-taught um which isn't
grammar but
um i'm lacking grammar today um
books are my passion too and they were
really my outlet to
my journey of learning and would you
ever come back on the show
and do book reviews with him do a book
club do anything with books us and jonah
on the show
of course i would love to okay i was so
nervous because i was so invested and
excited at the idea
reagan let's do this okay i want to it'd
be so much fun
oh my gosh everybody you can catch
reagan on young sheldon every thursday
at 8 30
7 30 central on c b
we'll see you soon
[Music]
bye